back I'm sorry there's more room
but come on in if anybody is sitting
next to an empty seat I feel like I'm at
a wedding if there's anybody sitting
next to an empty seat raise your hand oh
there are no hands raised okay well then
I'm just gonna plunge in yes so my plan
is to tell you about 13.7 years a
billion years of cosmic evolution I'm
gonna talk for about 40 minutes you can
imagine that I will leave out some
details in fact I'll probably leave out
citations to all your colleagues and
mine not quite not quite I do want to
talk about this this is a special moment
really because the recognition that
these exploding stars like this one can
tell you about the structure of the
universe and the location of the
galaxies and the history of cosmic
expansion is the message I have for you
today coming events cast their shadows
before them
the Gruber cosmology prize was awarded
for this work to the Heisey supernova
team and the supernova cosmology project
the two groups that were working on this
and then just in November well in
December we all went to Stockholm for
the Nobel Prize so let me tell you a
word about that and we'll get that out
of the way I have to say this is
actually a more August group than you
would find on the stage at the Nobel
Prize ceremonies because although
there's some super-duper scientists on
the on the stage they're also the
shreditor you know hereditary nobility
and economists so you know all the same
so this prize was awarded to Saul
Perlmutter to Brian Schmidt and Adam
riess for the discovery of the
accelerating expansion of the universe
through observations of distant
supernovae and what I'm going to tell
you about is the discovery of the
accelerating expansion of the universe
through observations of distant
supernovae and I feel I can do this
because we all wore the right clothes
that's me over there here are the guys
who won the Miss so here's Adam and
Brian who won the Nobel Prize
both of
them were my graduate students and they
forgot to wear the little buttons I made
for them when they were on the stage
apparently that's not considered proper
protocol so this story starts sort of in
1917 1916 with Albert Einstein trying to
think about applying his newly invented
general relativity to the universe as a
whole and what astronomers assured him
was the universe is this the Milky Way
galaxy the galaxy in which we live shall
we dim the lights a little there's a
danger that people will fall asleep but
I'll talk louder and that will you know
that will irritate them so much they'll
stay awake okay that's good yeah that's
good okay so here is the Milky Way of
course there's no place on earth where
you can stand and see the whole Milky
Way this is both the northern and the
southern part what turns out to be
interesting is that the astronomers of
1917 assured Einstein this was the
universe but in fact it's not and it's
these little fuzzy things which we call
galaxies which they called nebulae back
then
which turned out to be the interesting
thing but that was not known at the time
when Einstein set up his interpretation
of general relativity for the universe
now here's a picture of Einstein the
thing I want to emphasize is technology
and the change in technology here's a
picture of Einstein taken with
photographic technology light falls on
silver halides and people dip things
into chemicals and the silver becomes
metal and oh my goodness it's quite a
complicated thing compared to using a
CCD I'll tell you that anyway what you
can see is that chemical process is
actually quite inefficient and during
the time the shutter was open while
Einstein was looking at the camera
this guy was clearly in disagreement
with Einstein and this person got up and
left
if you take a picture today using a
digital imager under low-light
conditions like that you'd still have
that other guy in the picture and you
wouldn't know what this person was
thinking now that's the other thing we
have developed methods now for finding
out what people were thinking and what's
interesting is that Einstein was
thinking the universe must be static
that this universe which was the Milky
Way made of stars whose velocities were
small and not systematic not coming or
going
from us he thought that the universe
must be static but it turns out that the
other half of the technological piece
here is the development of telescopes
and as the world war one ended the
operation of big telescopes that George
Ellery Hale had been building at Mount
Wilson this is the mountain up behind
Pasadena near Los the little village of
Los Angeles which had 25,000 people and
very little street lighting at the time
here's the telescope that they built I
draw your attention to this chair up
here ooh there's the chair and in a
second I'll show you somebody sitting in
that chair
operating the telescope and exposing a
photographic plate what people
discovered in the early part of the 20th
century were where they were able to
measure the distances inside the Milky
Way galaxy using this telescope and
others by looking at stars whose
brightness we know so by measuring how
bright they appear you can figure out
how far away they are and it's from that
kind of measurement that we know that
the Milky Way galaxy in which we live
and which New Haven is located about
their Milky Way galaxy in which we live
is about a hundred thousand light-years
across so it take it would take light
traveling at the speed of light which is
not just a metaphor but an actual speed
the speed it's a the speed of light is a
foot in a nanosecond
in a billionth of a second so it takes
time for light to travel across this
room so I see the people in the front as
they not as they are but as they were
six or eight nanoseconds ago and
curiously the people in the back look
younger because I see the light that was
emitted from them quite a long time ago
now that's just an amusing idea in this
room but of course in the universe this
is not a joke that the telescope
actually works as a time machine and
lets us see the light that was emitted
at in the past so we can actually see
the light from the past and that's what
Hubble was doing at the hundred inch
telescope here is at that chair
photographic plate would be mounted up
here and those big wheels are to keep
the telescope pointed exactly at the
same place as it tracks across the sky
Edwin Hubble was able to show by the
same technique I just described finding
stars in these fuzzy nebulae which were
the same as stars in our own galaxy and
in the other systems we knew about he
could find those stars measure their
brightness and from their apparent
brightness figure out how far away the
nebulae were and what he showed was the
our own Milky Way has a dimension of
roughly a hundred thousand light-years
the distances to the nearby nebulae are
ten times as big a million light-years
and so it's no problem and you can do it
on a fall night you can get well not
quite downtown but anyway if you go
outside it down a little bit you can see
the light from the Andromeda nebula from
m31 which Hubble worked on to measure
the distances and to show that the Milky
Way is not the whole universe it's a
universe of galaxies each of which is
more or less equivalent to the Milky Way
and Edwin Hubble wrote a famous book the
realm of the nebulae which is was
published by Yale University Press it
was a silliman lecture and it's going to
have a new edition with a new forward
and I'm writing it okay
I promise I sign the contracts on the
contract okay so here's the Andromeda
nebula Hubble was able to see individual
stars in this and show that these this
fuzzy thing was not in the Milky Way
these are in fact the constituents of
the universe and this is not what
Einstein understood in 1917 there's
something else about those galaxies
that's interesting not only are they far
from us but they are moving away from us
and the way we know that is by measuring
the light from this from these galaxies
spreading it out into a spectrum and
seeing that the lines which are caused
by the atoms in the atmospheres of the
stars the lines in the spectra of the
galaxies are stretched to the red by the
expansion of the universe the fellow who
did this to start with is shown here
Vesto melvin Slifer who worked at the
Lowell Observatory and he measured the
spectra of these nebulae and he found
that although there are few of them
coming toward us including the Andromeda
nebula that I showed you a second ago
which is approaching us check your
homeowners insurance most of the
galaxies are moving away from us
so here's a picture of Einstein visiting
the Mount Wilson Observatory library on
Santa Barbara Street in Pasadena the
library looks exactly the same in fact
they haven't even erased the blackboard
as far as I know Einstein here's
Michelson he won the Nobel Prize good
good work
here's Hubbell he did not win the Nobel
Prize here is George Ellery Hale patting
hubble on the head congratulations he
said you've done fine work here's
hama-san who actually measured the
redshift that's good well anyway here
they are Einstein visiting Mount Wilson
after the discovery of the thing we call
Hubble's law which is the idea that
these two things the distances that
Hubble was measuring and the velocities
which at first were being measured by
Slifer and then later by hummus inand
and Sandidge no but yeah Wells edges do
Amundson and oh my goodness and hubble
in the later sandwich that the
velocities and the distance were
proportional to one another so here are
Hubble's distances out this way
notoriously inaccurate but never mind
that
here are the velocities these were
actually taken from Slifer without
citation but that's alright and here is
the relation between velocity and
distance as first seen in 1929
we call this Hubble's law Hubble called
it Figure 1 where you can see that as
you look at more distant galaxies you
see a trend toward a higher velocity
away from us so what's the
interpretation of that well Meg was kind
enough to mention that I'm at Harvard
and there most of the students and all
of the faculty believe that they
personally are at the center of the
universe and so most of them have this
picture in their mind when you talk
about the Hubble law they say well it
must be me I must be at the center of
things and the other galaxies somehow
know enough to receive from us well I'm
here to tell you that that is not the
current picture the current picture is
of course that the universe that's out
there a universe of galaxies is
stretching apart in all directions and
that there's nothing special or at least
we think there's nothing special about
our own galaxy that distinguishes it
from the others so you know if you think
of the history of science you think of
people imagining that the earth was at
the center of the universe most of you
have heard this is not the current idea
then there might be the notion well all
right the earth goes around the Sun
maybe the Sun was at the center of
things no I just showed you a picture it
you know everybody laughed when I said
New Haven way out there the Sun our star
is not at the center of our own galaxy
and it seems like it would be kind of
willful misunderstanding for us to think
that out of all the galaxies out there
that somehow ours has a special or
privileged position so the question is
how do you understand Hubble's
aw where everyone's going away from us
and the idea that we have no special
position and of course the notion is
that we live in a universe that's
expanding in all directions and would
look the same to any observer now when
people teach this idea at large
universities or small they often resort
to a very homely sort of metaphor which
I found on a NASA website and here it
shows a loaf of a raisin bread which has
raisins in it and as the loaf rises all
the raisins get farther apart what's
more if you take the point of view of
any raisin you get this extended
metaphor if you take the a point of view
of any of these raisins you will see the
other raisins moving away from you
what's more the nearby raisins are
moving away from you slowly while the
distant ones moving more rapidly uh-huh
that is really dumb okay but I don't
have a better one today for reasons that
don't lift I'm doing all right
so what did Einstein do Einstein had put
into his equations by hand an extra term
the so-called cosmological term or
cosmological constant to make a static
universe because he thought that's what
the astronomers wanted but now the
astronomers are telling me it's
expanding so here's a vilem de sitter
who was a leading astronomer who
enlightened who could actually
understand what einstein had written and
translated it for many astronomers and
together they thought all right let's
get rid of that cosmological constant
this anti-gravity kind of a thing that
balances out the universe and we'll just
have a universe that's always expanding
and always decelerating isn't that what
you had in your paper yeah something
that in the secret language of
astronomers we call that - not the
deceleration would be positive and have
a value of 1/2 so we wanted to get rid
of the cosmological constant what's so
interesting is that's the way we used to
tell the story but you know after the
trip to Stockholm now we have to change
our story so we have to have new heroes
but from the past so here's a George
lumetri who has a kind of unusual
combination of initials after his name
so he was a Jesuit and he had a PhD from
MIT and he was one of the first people
to think in a physical way about what
the universe what the cosmic expansion
might be he imagined that there might
have been a hot dense Big Bang though he
that was a good thought and he thought
that the expansion might take place as
though the energy in the vacuum was
different from zero so the vacuum the
empty space was not devoid of properties
it had a property and the property it
had was a negative pressure a pressure B
equals minus Rho C squared to the that
we associate a pressure to the energy
density of the vacuum this is the
meaning of the cosmological constant
lambda so this it turns out this is just
what people say today as I'll show you
we we need something like this to make
the universe that we see today which is
an expanding one that is accelerating
expanding faster and faster over time
and the thing that can do that is a
negative pressure something that it's
like tension would be if maybe a better
word for it so here's la Mettrie who had
that idea and here is a kind of visual
visual representation of lambda the
cosmological constant making the
universe swell up this is from a Dutch
newspaper but English is a dialect of
Frisian so it's easy for us to read it
who however makes the ball makes the
blow out of the ball blow up with the
ball up what makes the but what makes
the ball up what makes the universe
expand or swell up ops welt that has to
be lambda you no other answer can be
given well pretty good okay I have it
written down here in case
tract okay so there is at least there
were at least some people in the 1930s
after the discovery of the expansion of
the universe who did not abandon the
cosmological constant and what I'll show
you is that the modern version now
requires something like it something
that acts like the cosmological constant
something that acts to make the universe
expand faster over time something that
acts like a negative pressure okay well
how did we learn that well it's the same
old story it says we have no ideas and
it's subject except we're looking at the
brightness of stars only this time the
stars that we're looking at our
exploding stars supernovae they're a
million times brighter than the stars
that Hubble used to measure the
distances to the galaxies back in the
1920s and that means we can see them
even with the same equipment a thousand
times as far away so instead of
measuring distances of a few million
light-years with this kind of explosion
you can measure distances of billions of
light-years and we think that the time
back to the Big Bang is about 13.7
billion years this means that we have a
way to measure those distances and those
times with good precision as I'll show
you over a fair fraction of the whole
age of the universe these exploding
stars so here's a galaxy galaxy has in
it about a hundred billion stars roughly
speaking and for a little while there's
one of them this is a star in that
galaxy exploding there's one of them
which is as bright as about four billion
stars like the Sun so we've measured
these things and it turns out that the
range of brightness for these stars is
fairly small and that's a key point
because it allows us to judge the
distances with good accuracy so this
sounds like exactly the right thing to
do you assign your graduate students
study that galaxies wait till a
supernova explodes measure its
brightness the problem is that they are
rare they're about one per century in a
galaxy for example we live in a galaxy
the Milky Way galaxy is anybody here
seen this
renova in the Milky Way galaxy well not
recently the last one in the Milky Way
galaxy was seen by Kepler and the one
before that was seen by Tycho and this
is a picture taken with an iPhone of
Tycho as he went outside his castle and
looked up there to see this bright star
up in Cassiopeia which is the supernova
1572 the one that we call Tycho's
supernova he just called it my supernova
supernova and if you go to look at that
spot now if you take an optical picture
you can see stars and some little bit of
light from the location
what's also shown here is x-ray emission
this green stuff is fluffy stuff is
x-ray emission from the hot interior of
this supernova remnant this is the
shredded star this is the material that
is left over after the star which is
mostly carbon and oxygen burns in a
sudden thermonuclear flash up to silicon
and iron and so silicon and iron are
things we see here the explosion goes
out into the gas between the stars and
makes this little Ridge of radio
emission that makes Tycho's supernova
remnant such a powerful radio source so
there are a lot of new things here a lot
of new technologies but it gives you the
idea for sure that there was a more or
less spherical explosion that took place
and and we can measure the expansion we
can see that this really is the event
from 1570 to now we should have an
interest in these things after all every
one of us has coursing through their
body red blood cells with hemoglobin in
them and you might ask yourself well
where did the iron that makes the
hemoglobin red come from and the answer
is supernova supernova that went off
before the formation of the earth and of
the Sun so in the sense we were all star
material that's a good thought I think
and we really are made from the ashes of
exploded stars here's something else
that's made from the ashes of exploded
stars it's a Pontiac and you might say
well where was this made you know in a
very short sighted person would say well
that was made in Detroit that's not the
whole story yes but it really was
manufactured in a supernova 3,200 pounds
of iron what a car okay
and we have some idea of how this
happens that at the end of its life a
star like the Sun will make a dense
little nugget of carbon and oxygen we
call a white dwarf it's held up by
quantum mechanical forces could be
stable but many stars are in binary
systems the Sun of course is not but
many stars are and we think that either
the merger of another white dwarf or the
transfer of mass from some neighbors
star some fairy generous neighbor leads
to the explosion of the white dwarf from
it leads to the phenomenon we see that
has been a that we use to measure the
distances to these things okay so so
here's something a little more modern
actually probably update this but anyway
this is a Hubble diagram for these
particular kind of exploding stars this
is distance out here and here's velocity
going up that way
for each supernova explosion on this
diagram we have measured how bright the
supernova is and from that inferred how
distant it is and then we've also
measured how much the spectrum is
stretched out by the expansion of the
universe and plotted that up here so
this is a plot of velocity and distance
the same thing that was on that Hubble
diagram from 1929 except Hubble's Hubble
diagram which fit in this little square
down here this little red square down
here Kremlin on one side boom department
store on the other you know anyway
here's the relation between velocity and
distance a nice straight line in this
plot of linear velocity versus distance
the distance is in mega parsecs just in
case the physicists walk into the room
we want to make sure that we have some
secret knowledge and they have to ask us
what is that that's a unit
of distance about three light-years and
so this picture covers sorry the most
distant supernova in the picture in this
little bit of the diagram are at a
distance of about two billion light
years so about one seventh of the way
back to the Big Bang this is just nearby
and the law is linear nearby okay and
here for the professionals just so
you'll feel more at home here's the
current or nearly current data sample
for several hundred supernovae and this
is a log log plot to suppress all errors
and what anyway and what you'll see here
is that the supernovae make very good
standard candles they make very good
distance estimators and they help us
determine the current rate of expansion
to good precision to a few percent we
think we know the rate at which the
universe is expanding today and that was
done by Malcolm Hickman who has a
graduate student of mine just a couple
of years ago okay so now we that's
nearby universe expanding and we have a
tool that we can use to great distances
so now we're ready we're ready to ask
the question what's the history of
cosmic expansion we want to look deep
into the past now this picture was taken
with a charge-coupled device a silicon
detector like the thing that's in a
camera that you could buy people used to
buy cameras now they just have phones
with exhilarate to weapons anyway this
is a picture taken by starlight and it's
not a very long exposure and you can see
the four meter dome at Sara to Lolo you
can see our Milky Way the clouds of
Magellan over there
and there's no problem taking a picture
by starlight with these modern detectors
compared to the chemical detectors the
silver halide detectors they're about a
hundred times more efficient so the same
telescope using this kind of instrument
is a hundred times better
than the old instruments then that then
the old methods on the same telescopes
okay and here's what we want to do we're
here's a diagram that's supposed to show
you how the universe has changed think
of it as the distance between any two
galaxies so here two galaxies and over
time if the universe is expanding the
distance is getting bigger so that's
what this is on the vertical axis the
distance between two galaxies if the
universe is expanding but slowing down
decelerating this curve will curve
downward if the universe is accelerating
I hate to spoil the surprise but this is
what we're going to find the if the
universe is accelerating then as time
goes by that distance will increase more
rapidly so here's the present it's no
time like the present we'll look back
into the past and make a plot of how big
the universe was at different distances
or different times in the past and we
can do that with the two things that I
talked about measuring the brightness of
the supernova and the stretching of its
spectrum that's enough information to
put a point on this kind of diagram what
we're not so good at is seeing into the
future okay otherwise astronomers be
very wealthy people we do not see into
the future we don't know for sure
whether the expansion of the universe
that we see today
will persist or not if the universe is
dominated today by a dark energy which
is exactly like the cosmological
constant then the expansion will be
literally exponential the rate will
depend on the current value of the size
and that will be the future of the
universe and it's possible that it
increases even faster than that which is
hardly worth thinking hardly bears
thinking about okay so here's one of
those this is a Bevo who is my thesis
advisor here he is very happy because he
is holding one of the world's largest
charge-coupled devices at the time
yes 0.2 4 megapixels
here's a modern picture of an astronomer
this is John Henry what a member of the
Heisey team and he's happy too you can
tell he's having even though you can't
see his mouth you can tell he's happy
and he's got an array here of silicon
which is as big as the photographic
plates that Hubble had which is got in
it a thousand megapixels a Giga pixel oh
no wonder he's so happy and this is the
kind of detector with which you can make
measurements that allow you to survey
many galaxies and look for distant
supernovae explosions as I'll show you
in a second so we didn't have a detector
quite as good as that one but anyway we
had something in between during the time
when Brian Schmidt was a graduate
student so here's Brian Schmidt
explaining to his thesis adviser how
easy it's going to be to find distant
supernovae all he has to do is write the
software and I said well that's all very
good but you know there's this other
team Saul Perlmutter steamed the
supernova cosmology project they've been
working on this for five years and
that's three people or maybe four so
that's 15 man years of software effort
and he said yes he said yes it probably
will take me all month and so hid and it
did and it was terrible software we just
to break all the time and it wouldn't
only work anyway but it did work that
did work here's the idea the idea is
these are digital images so here's a
picture of a little piece of the sky
from let's say tonight and here's a
picture that you have stored in the
memory of your computer from some other
time say a month ago
turns out these supernovae take about a
month to get bright so since these are
digital images arrays of numbers you can
literally subtract one from the other
there are some subtleties to this but
anyway you can't subtract one from the
other and that means that things that do
not change will go away
and you'll only have leftover the things
that are new in the picture from tonight
so this galaxy was in both picture
and when you look at the subtraction
it's gone but up here it's very hard to
tell what's going on
nevertheless when you take the
difference image there is a dot left
over and you're sure it's real because
there's a red circle around it it shows
that this is the real thing okay
the there are false positives this is
more complicated than I said but that is
basically the method and that meant we
could find distant supernovae measure
their brightness and infer their
distance and trace out this history of
cosmic expansion what Adam riess did was
as a student was to take into account
the way in which dust in other galaxies
and in our own would diminish the light
from a distant supernova you can see in
this picture that there are these clouds
of dust in this particular direction
which are absorbing some of the light
from behind if you had a supernova that
was behind a cloud of dust it would look
dimmer than it ought to for its distance
in other words if you saw it and you
didn't know about the cloud of dust
you'd say oh that supernova must be
farther away as if the expansion of the
universe had been bigger over the time
while the light was in travel to you as
if the universe were accelerating so the
point is you cannot tell the difference
until you solve this problem you cannot
tell the difference between the universe
with boring old dust in it and a
universe with this very exciting
accelerating property of the universe
many people prefer dust but well show
but we learned how to make these
measurements we're quite sure that
that's not the right story and Adam
really got going on that for his thesis
so here's a picture of Adam with in
Massachusetts it's ok to have two dads
and here's bill press who's now and
here's me that's a funny picture ok ok
so Adam work on this business of
measuring the distances to things so
here's the idea again
the supernova is a rare thing it's one
in a one in a century one in a hundred
years century hundred years that's one
in five thousand weeks okay take a few
couple of weeks up for vacation so if
you look at five thousand galaxies your
chances of finding a nice fresh
supernova are pretty good they're pretty
good and if you look in this picture
well you see galaxy galaxies galaxies
galaxies galaxies but the ones were
really interested in are not these nice
big ones where you can see what's going
on there these these are galaxies - and
by doing this subtraction very very well
you can tell whether one of those has
brightened by ten percent or so whether
there is a supernova explosion in one of
these distant galaxies then you can go
out and measure it carefully and you can
measure the redshift the the stretching
of the light and put it on the diagram
to measure the history of cosmic
expansion well as I mentioned there were
two groups in the field and here we have
Brian and here's Saul Perlmutter and we
had full and frank exchange of views on
some important topics they published
first and here's the publication
measurements of the cosmological
parameters from seven supernovae and
what they found was the Omega matter
that is the fraction of the universe
that's made up of gravitating stuff was
0.88 pretty close to one for a lambda
equals zero cosmology for a no dark
energy the results are inconsistent with
lambda dominated low-density flat
cosmologies that's the right answer are
inconsistent with the right answer that
have been proposed to reconcile the ages
of globular cluster stars with higher
Hubble constant values so the first work
was a very small sample and it seemed to
point in the direction of a universe
that was slowing down but things got
better fast we were working in the field
and they also were getting more data
Adam was a student at the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology and there
although they don't do a lot of poetry
they learn to keep lab notebooks and
here is his lab
notebook and says up there Hubble
results of blah blah blah and so on and
it turns out he says well if he assumes
that the universe has no cosmological
constant no dark energy then he gets the
fraction of the universe that's in the
form of gravitating matter was minus
0.36 Adam needs a lot of feedback so he
called me up he said I got the result
and it's minus 0.36 and I said yeah I
think I think you might have made a
mistake here how could you get negative
mass he said well well good point yes
I'll go back and check this anyway we
checked this as carefully as we could
and found that this was of course the
problem was not the value of the mass
it's that we had assumed there was no
cosmological constant no acceleration
and you can find another solution that
matches the data if you allow for that
so you need something the universe is
actually speeding up and I probably I
should speed up too okay because all the
funny stuff is at the end so here's a
here's one of those diagrams I showed
you before before I showed you that the
points were lying on a diagonal line and
that was good
now you can't really see it but these
lines diverge this is the history of the
universe shown on that kind of diagram
of redshift and brightness redshift and
distance and the idea is that if the
universe is speeding up or slowing down
it'll make a difference in this diagram
here's how it works
supernova goes off the light travels
from it to you and during the time it's
in flight the universe expands if the
universe is slowing down then the
distance that it has to travel is
smaller if the universe is speeding up
the distance it has to travel is bigger
and the universe and the supernovae will
appear a little dimmer and so you can
see here we've drawn these different
lines taken out the 45 degrees now and
what you see is if the universe were
slowing down the way most people
expected especially if they had read
that other paper anyway people if they
were universe were slowing down the way
most people expected it would lie along
this line
if the universe were slowing down but
just by the amount you'd expect for the
amount of matter we are pretty sure is
present in the universe it would be on
this horizontal line now you do not have
the advantage of the powerful tools of
Bayesian inference that we used on this
meager data set with the big Earth's but
the points really do lie above that line
and that's the direction of acceleration
that's the direction of a universe
that's speeding up and while the data
here are pretty noisy nevertheless it
they make a good case for the universe
that has in it both dark energy and dark
matter so now here's the first of these
spooky diagrams this makes you uneasy
just close your eyes for a minute it
will pass this way is the is the amount
of dark energy this way is the amount of
dark matter or met gravitating matter
and the evidence from the supernova
picked out this part of the diagram
these big Zeppelin's up here and what
you can see is that the heart of the
diagram is up here for high values of
the cosmological constant or something
like it's something that makes the
universe speed up and well okay so
that's the old day it seemed and what we
show here is the data from both groups
that's right the solid lines of course
are us that the dashed lines are the
other guys and you can see that from the
data the two data sets which are mostly
independent we got the same result
here's a modern version of the data
where what we've been doing over the
last ten years of course is filling this
in many more points at high redshift and
higher redshifts many in the middle many
at low redshift and here's that
horizontal line that corresponds to the
fit only this time the fit is a curved
line you can't see it then I can oh yeah
it's a curved line that corresponds to a
universe that's speeding up so the
modern data really does confirm this
early result here's a way to see that
here's that old diagram I showed you
before and that you can see the error
ellipse
on there here's the modern error ellipse
from the current data sets and the
supernova data have gone from being this
great big uncertainty to this small one
by hard work by building up the data set
and we're very you know that's been a
worldwide effort a lot of people have
done it those people in Sweden are very
conservative you know they don't want to
give out a prize for something that's
totally wrong and I think the evidence
has been coming in over the intervening
decade or so that really shows that this
idea is right that the universe is
accelerating here I show some other
things here's this supernova ellipse and
then this green thing has to do with
galaxy clustering it turns out the
history of the gathering together of
matter in the universe depends on the
amount of matter and the history of the
expansion so it turns out that this
which you can measure intersects with
the supernova somewhere up here this is
a line that reflects evidence from the
glow from the Big Bang itself the Cosmic
Microwave Background these of course any
two lines have to cross but three lines
don't have to cross in this thing in the
same place the fact that they do is a
good sign I think and it converges on
this picture where the universe is about
two-thirds dark energy and one-third the
dark matter or dark gravitating matter
so that's kind of a funny picture if you
if you ask what is it that the
supernovae really tell you
turns out they tell you about the age of
the universe if you I've plotted here
lines of constant age 10 11 12 13
billion years 14 billion years 15
billion years and what you can see is
that the supernova observations
laia pretty much along those lines and
they pick out a solution which is this
age of the universe of about 13.7
billion years okay so this seems to be
real was been endorsed by the Gruber
Prize in cosmology the Nobel Prize in
Physics and the Maine Department of
Motor Vehicles which has
accelerating universe license plate
which was issued to me and at the Nobel
Prize ceremony you know Adam and Brian
kind of felt sorry for the rest of us
because you know they got the big gold
medal but we got we got the cufflinks
which they had made which are Q not less
than zero that's astronomer talk for an
accelerating universe so we wear those
whenever we're in the company of the
supernova cosmology project and here is
more evidence this is from the glow from
the Big Bang that I talked about before
what it really tells you about is the
some of the energy that's in gravitating
matter and the part of the universe
that's in this associated with the
vacuum this dark energy we know that
there's dark matter in the universe
there's no doubt about it
we see its effects we see the bending of
light you can see here these arcs which
are the result of the mass that's
associated with these galaxies even
though it's not glowing even though it's
not stars that are glowing there is a
lot more mass in clusters of galaxies
and in galaxies themselves including the
Milky Way galaxy there's a lot more mass
than is in the visible stars and so this
solution
that corresponds to the things that I
just mentioned the clustering of
galaxies and to the Cosmic Microwave
Background is what gives you this rather
well-defined value in which the about
two-thirds in the universe is in this
form of the stuff that makes the
universe speed up which we call the dark
energy so here's a diagram that shows
the dark energy most of the universe the
dark matter turns out we know from other
arguments about the cooking in the Big
Bang that most of that cannot be in the
form of the atoms of the periodic table
it can't be made of neutrons and protons
that neutrons and protons the stuff
we're made of can only be about 4% of
the universe the
Dark Matter is about 23% and the dark
energy the balance now my theoretical
colleagues are extremely proud of this
diagram they say look it is full you
should always ask what is it full of and
and in this case it is full of our most
important resource which is ignorance or
as we like to call it opportunity there
are things that means that somebody in
this room has a chance to find out what
the dark matter is and somebody in this
room and it's not me has a chance to
find out what the dark energy is there's
a lot missing in this picture I don't
know how it makes you feel either to be
part of the 4% but it doesn't seem very
sensible I'll tell you that here's a
picture of someone wearing a t-shirt
that's my wife and here's what the
t-shirt says the universe is under no
obligation to make sense but your PhD
thesis better I didn't make these
t-shirts I bought it I bought it and
when I went to the place where they had
them have a funny story I guess I went
to the place where they have them I said
hey I'm Robert P Kirchner they said
we'll give you a good discount so what
is this dark energy well one way to find
out what it might be in the old days
before the academic institutions with an
agenda to promote started camping out on
the on the web to get there you know so
the so that you would find them it used
to be that when you would Google dark
energy you got this from American
hydroponics this is plant food so that
you can grow controlled substances in
your closet it says I'm the advertising
copy says these specialized processes
are also responsible for the very
distinct odor of dark energy so we don't
know what it is but we know it smells
bad if you ask a theoretical physicist
would you kindly estimate for me the
energy associated with gravitation in
the vacuum they will do it they shoot
their cuffs they pull
out there Mon Blanc pen they take an
envelope and look on the back and here's
the envelope and they write something
that has the Planck mass to the fourth
power in it which is a very big number
here it's ten to the hundred and
twentieth okay it might only be ten to
the sixtieth anyway
ten to one hundred and twentieth the one
with 120 zeroes where the correct answer
is 0.7 in academic circles we say it's
not good quantitative agreement it's a
sure sign that we don't understand
quantum gravity and that's you know
that's no that's not exactly news there
are other possibilities about the dark
energy it might be something that is not
exactly the cosmological constant it
could be something for example there's
cosmological but not constant could
change over time and if that's true that
ought to be reflected in the history of
cosmic expansion two people have talked
about modifications to gravity and to
change the way in which gravity works on
large scales because after all it's only
tested on medium scales like the solar
system you can do that but it's very
tricky and Einstein was very good and
had an excellent solution to the
big-scale problem and people have had
well I wouldn't say any real great
success in picking an alternative theory
that other people would say that's great
usually it's one person one theory in
this field the other thing to say and
this is actually an important point is
that you can't tell the whole story from
the expansion history alone so what I've
been talking about is using the
supernovae to measure the history of
cosmic expansion and it turns out that's
not enough to exclude some of these
other ideas you need other information
which can come from the way in which
galaxies have clustered over time which
I alluded to briefly ok so what about
this dark energy is it the cosmological
constant or not well we have developed a
language for this and the language is
this index W this is I didn't know how
to turn it anyway W which is it tells
the relation between it the equation of
state the relation between pressure and
density
for the dark energy you may remember I
had that slide a long time ago with la
Mettrie and the Metro said oh look the
dark energy acts are the vacuum acts or
the cosmological constant acts as if the
vacuum has a property as if it has a
pressure that's minus Rho C squared and
that would be minus one in this picture
so the prediction from the 1930s is that
this ought to be minus one and you can
see that the current evidence where this
is meant to be a representation of the
probability that you can get all of
these data to agree with your model the
the evidence is pretty good well anyway
it's as good it's as good there's no
evidence that it's not minus one that is
there's no evidence that the
cosmological constant is wrong how can
we do better though we could make those
error smaller and suppose it was at
point nine five or 1.05 that would be
really interesting if it turned out that
the value of that number was not minus
one and I'll talk tomorrow to the
astronomers and physicists about ways
that we think we can do that by making
observations at other wavelengths out in
the infrared
well I can't recommend a better book on
this subject than this one I would just
say that in the big picture that this
dark energy puzzle is a sure sign that
we do not understand everything about
gravity we don't know how to understand
how to combine gravity with quantum
physics and this is again not news but
it means this is another manifestation
of that ongoing problem okay I was gonna
so tomorrow I'm gonna talk about the
future and how to make other
measurements now I'll just stop with the
per oration so I'm gonna skip ahead to
the peroration this you know sorry you
have to come to the talk tomorrow to get
the the directed acyclic graph and all
that stuff that I know you want I do
want to say one thing though because
there's always the possibility that
there's someone in the room who's going
to be on the space
telescope time allocation committee and
they won't understand the acronym unless
I explain it to them very slowly so
here's the idea
supernova 1a that's that's kind of
supernovae we're using in the infrared
scramble those letters around and you
get raisin which of course is the the
archetypal tracer of cosmic expansion
whoo okay so I'm not gonna explain all
this stuff I'm gonna skip to the and a
skip to the philosophical stuff so
here's the idea
we live in a universe where we can
there's some things we can observe
exploding stars and distant galaxies
they give us the history of cosmic
expansion they tell us about invisible
forces at work you might say this is a
bad idea
the scientists have gone off the deep
end well not entirely you know if you
look outside and you see the trees
moving you say oh it's the wind but you
don't see the wind what you see is the
effect of the wind you see how it makes
things move and in the same way we think
that this battle this kind of tug of war
between the dark matter trying to slow
things down the dark energy trying to
speed things up extends from the time of
the Big Bang back out as time goes by
that there would have been deceleration
at early times when the universe was
dense and then the acceleration has has
taken place recently and we see it in
this these measurements of the distant
objects okay I told you it was going to
be philosophical Plato
good I don't do this at MIT do they
so what Socrates says you know Socrates
did didn't publish much but he had good
graduate students that was good
Socrates says shall we make a strong to
me the next object of study what do you
say and Glaucon
haha buddy in his hands clock on says Oh
certainly a working knowledge of the
seasons months and years is a benefits
beneficial to everyone to commanders as
well as farmers and sailors and Socrates
says you'll make me smile but how come
you are so afraid that the public will
accuse you of recommending unprofitable
studies and in the same way I think we
should not be afraid to say that at
least some science ought to be on
subjects that are not mostly about being
beneficial to commanders and farmers but
our subjects that we study because we
want to know where we came from where we
are and where we're going and they it
turns out that Paul Gauguin studied this
if you go to the Museum of Fine Arts in
Boston of course there is this kind of
allegorical painting of tahini where yes
where do we come from
where are we where are we going thank
you very much
yeah yeah yeah they didn't get all the
way in though did they yeah yeah I
certainly will so the question is and we
in for anything about the shape of the
universe and now you're got in trouble
well I know I know where is the
direction to the origin of the Big Bang
so here's where you have to be very
careful remember I was making fun of
those people like like Socrates talking
to grab calm I was making fun of people
who thought that the earth was at the
center of the universe or that the Sun
was at the center of the universe or
that our galaxy was at the center of the
universe and in the same way we think
that the Big Bang would be everywhere in
the universe at that early time here's
the way to think about it we look out
now in all directions and we see this
glow from the Big Bang from 13.7 billion
years ago well ok suppose it was 3.7
billion years earlier then you would
look 10 billion years light-years in all
directions and if you go back and back
and back that anywhere any point you
picked you wouldn't see in all
directions the the universe and it would
be a hotter denser place when you got
back 13.7 billion years you'd be in the
Big Bang and so would anybody else okay
that's the part where I had to wave my
hands quite a bit yep yes yes so there's
Henrietta Leavitt worked at the Harvard
College Observatory first sort of as a
volunteer then she was paid 25 cents an
hour it was her work that discovered
this law of
the properties of the Cepheid variable
stars the vibration of those stars that
Hubble employed to measure the distances
to nearby galaxies and her work was very
important and I think she is underrated
although she did in fact get to publish
that work under her own name which was
good but you know in the time it was the
observatory director Pickering who had a
vision of how to run the observatory and
his idea was to run the observatory he
said like a railroad that it would be
and you would have people work at the
lowest possible wage under careful
supervision of course and he hired women
to do this so he hired women from
Radcliffe which was just getting going
from Wellesley from other places around
very talented people who you know on the
positive side this was an opportunity
for them to do real scientific research
on the negative side but it was
Pickering you know sort of organizing
this big effort and and mostly taking
credit for it nevertheless it was a very
interesting kind of moment and so both
Henrietta Leavitt who I think is kind of
under you know under appreciated and and
lumetri are people whose contributions I
think we see more clearly now than
people did in the not so distant past
yeah yeah
right so what about the car yes I
skipped over that didn't I that wasn't
very good at me what about the curvature
space okay so you know Einstein's theory
of general relativity is a theory in
which the presence of matter and energy
curves space and so the geometry of the
universe is set by its constituents the
thing that's so interesting is that the
dark energy has this negative pressure
so it can contribute to the total energy
density of the universe and raise that
up while at the same time having this
kind of anti-gravity quality so that's
an extra Philip that if if you go back
and look in an astronomy book from 1990
people just don't put that in here this
way that's stupid
Einstein thought that was a big mistake
so now the question is what is the what
is the property of the universe and the
geometric property and the way you
measure it is just the way you measure
curvature you might measure curvature if
you knew that an object of given size
and you see it at different distances
you measure the angle and it turns out
this these fluctuations in the Cosmic
Microwave Background are a thing whose
size we know because we understand the
physics of that and by measuring the
angular size of those fluctuations which
is about one degree which was first done
in about the year 2000 so just after the
acceleration results people have been
able to conclude with very good
confidence now that the geometry of the
universe is the geometry of flat space
the Euclidean geometry that we learned
in high school the more interesting more
complicated kinds of geometry that might
take place on a curved surface either
curve like a saddle if the density is
low or curve like a sphere if the
density is high seems not to describe
the large-scale properties of the
universe in which we live
so for mathematicians you know it's a
great thing to have worked all of this
out the particular universe in which we
happen to live seems to be one
in which the large-scale geometry is
flat to two fairly good precision a few
percent I did but well that's a good
question I think the right thing to say
is that all the other forces in nature
are quantum theories so we know about
electromagnetism and the difference
between a universe and you know where
electromagnetism operates in a setting
where there are particles and their
antiparticles their virtual particles
being created and destroyed all the time
which is this kind of lively quantum
picture for the vacuum that picture
agrees better with the measurements for
electromagnetism than a picture in which
you imagine the space having no
properties so that's a point for that
the strong and the weak nuclear forces
are also theories of the same character
the question is you know what kind of
theory will the proper theory of gravity
end up being I don't know the story you
know and nobody does really but of
course the the one of the promising
approaches that people have is string
theory in which the in which gravitation
looks like the other forces in which the
way you describe it is the same
mathematical language as the other
forces so that's a very promising and
intriguing aspect of string Theory's
that makes people know it's not evidence
no no it's I don't think there is
evidence I think there's a kind of oh
this is a people are this is the
frontier and people are trying to think
their way to the right idea about the
frontier and I would say that at the
moment there's a very weedy garden of
possible ideas with hundreds of ideas
most of which are wrong okay but it's
very hard to tell which are the right
ones in which are the wrong ones the
experimental evidence is kind of weak
there's no measurement in the laboratory
that tells you about these things only
cosmic things only astronomical
seemed to you know because the force of
gravity is so weak they are the only
ones that seem to bear on this question
really effectively so it's kind of an
unfortunate situation you know
astronomers knew that the speed of light
was finite in the 1600s because they
knew the eclipses of the moons of
Jupiter you know you had to take into
account whether the earth was on the
same side of the Sun or the other side
because it takes 15 minutes to get
across and once clocks were good enough
you know people measured that in the
1600s but measuring the speed of light
in the laboratory was hard and it wasn't
until the 1830s or 40s you know that
people were actually able to measure the
speed of light in the lab so I think
we're in a similar situation where you
know we see the cosmic effects of these
things but we have not yet developed
laboratory ways to analyze them and you
know it's something to be hoped for but
the history of doing experiments about
gravity is you know not got a lot of big
check marks for being able to do these
things so it's really hard and we hope
that people will invent ways to do it
and that it'll go it'll turn from being
a subject that's only in the
astronomical realm to one where there
really is experimental evidence on the
earth ah yes
yeah well that is part of the picture of
how particles work and how they get
their mass and so on at CERN their
principal activity now is to make it
sound like they're doing astronomy that
that they what they said you were
everything you read is we are recreating
the conditions of the Big Bang so
they've learned